One reason to build this network
by stacking simple operations,
like multiplications, and sums,
and RELUs, on top of each other is
that it makes the math very simple.
Simple enough that a deep learning
framework can manage it for you.
The key mathematical
insight is the chain rule.
If you have two functions
that get composed, that is,
one is applied to
the output of the other,
then the chain rule tells you that you
can compute the derivatives of that
function simply by taking the product
of the derivatives of the components.
That's very powerful.
As long as you know how to write
the derivatives of your individual
functions, there is a simple graphical
way to combine them together and
compute the derivative for
the whole function.
There's even better news for
the computer scientist in you.
There is a way to write this chain rule
that is very efficient computationally,
with lots of data reuse, and that looks
like a very simple data pipeline.